couple days after his 26th birthday
Justin Bieber stopped by Ellen today to
answer some burning questions including
if him and Haley will be starting a
family soon how many kids do you want to
have uh I think it's up to Haley because
it's her body good answer Haley Bieber
I'm nervous nervous this is me I'm
nervous she smells like like ariana
grande's perfume she smells good it's a
good smell I worry and like fruity and
it's like it's good all right
i annoy Haley when I constantly singing
around the house she likes it
but then there's a point where I think I
don't know I don't know what I feel like
she loves me a regardless of anything I
do but thinking around the house is not
annoying Justin okay maybe wouldn't you
know they pay for that yeah what is
Haley's pet name for you well she calls
me a bunch of weird things she calls me
goo goo just kind of weird but I like it
I like goo goo good good good you call
her goo goo as well I do she's got me
wrapped around her finger but yeah so
you say goo goo when she says Google
yeah we're both each other's goo Goo's
that's cute boss is so happy to see
Justin happy he will always have haters
was rising above rumor says they should
have called this to Haley edition no it
says that was a good answer about the
kids what's wrong with just saying I
want three she wants to but really we'll
figure it out yeah you can see you can
even see now anymore like you haven't
you have kind of any opinion anymore
whoever says I like Ariana's perfume too
when he started that answer is like is
he saying I know she smells like ariana
grande yeah thought he said the perfume
like yeah
yeah scandalous I know yeah it's nice to
see Bieber that I'm telling you I know I
know I've been harder than most on
Justin Bieber and the foolishness over
the years I am loving this Justin Bieber
loving him I think he's fun he is humble
he's I don't know I just I like this
just to Beaver a lot Veronica says
they're still in the lovey-dovey
honeymoon phase
so what phase is the best know if I'm I
shouldn't say that I've been Cather for
years now listen it's a great part okay
one of the many great parts one of the
many Thank You Graham great part and
it's up to her to decide on which parts
are the greatest
[Laughter]